lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
calcular la rapidez mínima que debe
tener este auto para estar en la cima de
este rizo y poder permanecer en esta
ruta o movimiento circular y no caer al
vacío creo que todos podemos apreciar
que esta es la parte más difícil de la
ruta en la parte inferior se ve que la
pista está proporcionando el soporte a
la fuerza centrípeta para mantener el
movimiento circular
pero al llegar a la cima pues tenemos a
la gravedad que va a estar jalando el
auto hacia abajo y el auto tendrá que
mantener una velocidad mínima para poder
permanecer en un movimiento circular
vamos a calcular cuál es la velocidad
mínima
a esto pues necesitamos saber cuál es el
radio de esta ruta circular
para hacer esto bueno desde esta imagen
no se ve que sea un círculo perfecto
parece más una elipse pero asumamos que
se trata de un círculo para mantener los
cálculos sencillos
entonces
bueno aunque no es un círculo perfecto
pues vamos a asumir a usarlos a subir
qué es un círculo perfecto
entonces bueno nuestra fórmula de
aceleración es la vimos en los vídeos
anteriores y es la aceleración
centrípeta es igual a la velocidad la
magnitud de la velocidad del cuadrado
entre el radio
en este punto aquí arriba que es más
difícil la magnitud de nuestra
aceleración va a hacer de 9.8 metros por
segundo que es la aceleración de la
gravedad y podemos estimar el radio al
copiar y pegar esta imagen del auto y
ponerla a una encima de otra pude poner
cuatro veces esta imagen hasta llegar
más o menos al centro del círculo
por lo que pude por lo que el radio del
mismo mire y busqué en internet y
encontré que la altura de este auto
desde un metro punto cinco un metro y
medio se pudiera poner cuatro imágenes
encima entonces una encima de otra
entonces el radio aproximado es de seis
metros
y con esto pues bueno vamos a despejar
las variables que nos interesen y lo
vamos a hacer de hecho con la fórmula
aún sin poner los valores de cuadrada
entre el radio es igual a la aceleración
el centrípeta multiplico ambos lados por
el radio me va a quedar velocidad del
cuadrado igual a la aceleración por
radio y ahora poniendo los valores si
quiero se le ver el valor de la
velocidad pues es la raíz cuadrada de la
aceleración por el radio entonces esta
velocidad voy a hacer calcularla con la
raíz principal de 9.81 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado multiplicado por el
radio de 6 metros no tendría el análisis
dimensional aquí es coherente
multiplicamos metros por metros nos
queda metro cuadrado entre segundo al
cuadrado al sacarla a reír nos quedarán
metros sobre segundos y vamos a hacer
los cálculos
vamos a poner en la raíz principal de
9.81 x 6 y nos va a dar 7 puntos 67 20
vamos a redondear lo a 7.7 más o menos o
7 puntos 67 metros por segundo
que realmente es una velocidad pues
bastante pequeña uno pensaría que
tendría que usarse una velocidad mayor
para poder superar esta ruta entonces
aproximadamente 7 puntos 7 metros por
segundo
y comedidos aproximado porque no podemos
medir el radio clear
si yo quiero obtener las unidades que
son más comunes en los autos que son
kilómetros por hora voy a multiplicar
esta cantidad por 3600 segundos que
tiene una hora y esto lo voy a
multiplicar por los kilómetros bueno por
los metros que hay en un kilómetro hay
mil metros en un kilómetro entonces aquí
pues tenemos que los metros se cancelan
con los metros los segundos con los
segundos nos quedan kilómetros por hora
y al hacer esta operación pues tenemos
el resultado anterior que vamos a
multiplicar por 3.600 y esto lo vamos a
dividir entre 1000
y la velocidad ahora sí en términos
conocidos cuando manejamos un auto van a
ser 27
punto 1.6 kilómetros por hora
como les comentaba esta es una velocidad
pues bastante lenta uno pensaría que
tendría que ir a una velocidad superior
para poder superar este ritmo pero no te
empieces a tener suficiente para
mantener esta ruta circular usted es lo
más seguro es que si se quedan con esta
velocidad pues es posible que sea el
auto no se mantenga en la pista y pues
puede resbalarse o caer
entonces los ojos que ustedes quieran
aumentar esta velocidad mínima pues para
tener un buen margen de seguridad
especialmente pues para mantener así que
la tracción del auto sobre la pista que
esto es lo que impide que caer a la del
siguiente vídeo lo que vamos a hacer es
calcular el tiempo que tardó la auto en
dar esta ruta para ver es bueno
asumiendo que tenemos la ruta circular
para calcular exactamente cuál fue la
velocidad promedio que mantuvo ese auto
al hacer este esta ruta